this is the anatomy of a mutiny the Sky
News data and forensics team in the
center for information resilience have
reviewed and verified more than 130
videos from bragogian's Brazen Convoy to
Moscow we can piece together exactly
what went on and how it went off the
rails the first action was in rustov on
Don this is the logistics hub for
Russian forces in Ukraine 42 of the
videos we reviewed are from here this
first clip was filmed near the Southern
military District headquarters you can
see men in military fatigues moving
through the city they face apparently no
opposition and around the same time in
the headquarters itself around the
corner Wagner group leader or perhaps
former Wagner group leader yeshni
progojin shared footage of himself
inside then Wagner starts moving vorage
is 350 miles north of rostov ondon along
the M4 Motorway unlike in rostov
onondondo here the group meets
resistance the first sign that this
Convoy isn't a stunt but an actual coup
things quickly get chaotic I'll take you
through this next video some of it is
hard to make out but the takeaway is
that it shows Russians fighting Russians
this was filmed in a car dealership on
the outskirts of the city men in green
fatigues thought to be Wagner Fighters
prepared to fire a likely anti-aircraft
missile and then as the vineyard
continues you can see their target it is
a Russian helicopter as it loops around
the building the missile is launched
just five minutes Drive South on the
same road another clip shows a
helicopter possibly the same one
narrowly evading a rocket one that
almost hits the person recording a
Wagner never made it inside Moscow but
the city was ready footage showed some
of the Russian military's movements as
it braced for potential armed
confrontation if Wagner's uncontested
takeover of rostov on Don mites have
made its actions look sanctioned even
stage managed in Moscow it was clear how
seriously the threat was being taken
trucks were deployed around the city and
Roblox like this one were constructed on
the approach routes footage like this
from inside Russia and footage of a
regime clearly on the back foot is rare
after the chaos of this coup we're
unlikely to have such a window in
anytime soon